Algunas personas utilizan las letras PAAU
para asegurar que están
multiplicando todos los términos de un paréntesis, por todos los términos del otro paréntesis.
Usa las letras PAAU
para multiplicar 3x más 2 por 5x -7.
Entonces lo primero que tenemos que hacer es recordar qué significa eso de las letras PAAU.
¿Ok? Tenemos por aquí PAAU
La P se refiere a lo primeros, primeros
y una de las A se refiere a los de afuera, afuera
y la otra A se refiere a los de adentro, adentro
¿Ok? Y finalmente la U se refiere a últimos, últimos.
Entonces tenemos que usar las letras PAAU para multiplicar 3x más 2
por 5x menos 7. Yo no soy un fan de usar este tipo de
nemotecnias, a mí me gusta mucho más utilizar la propiedad distributiva dos veces
pero es cierto que utilizar está PAAU
puede hacer que el cálculo sea más rápido.
Entonces pues vamos a usar PAAU. Tenemos que multiplicar
3x más 2 por
5x menos 7 y lo que nos dice nuestra buena amiga PAAU
es que tenemos que multiplicar primero los primeros términos de cada paréntesis
¿Ok? Este es el primer término de este paréntesis
y lo tenemos que multiplicar por el primer término de este otro paréntesis.
Entonces aquí tenemos
3x por 5x y después PAAU nos dice que tenemos que multiplicar los términos de afuera de los dos paréntesis
¿Ok? Este es un término de afuera por que está en el extremo izquierdo
y este con todo y su signo menos, es un término de afuera por que está en el extremo derecho,
y entonces tenemos que sumarle
3x por -7 y ahora PAAU dice que tenemos que
multiplicar los términos de adentro.
Estos son los términos de adentro entonces sumamos 2 por 5x
y finalmente PAAU dice que multipliquemos los últimos términos de cada paréntesis ¿Ok? Tenemos que
multiplicar este término con este término
entonces sumamos 2 por -7
¿Ok? Ya con PAAU estamos verificando que hayamos multiplicado
cada uno de estos términos de este paréntesis
por cada uno de los términos de este otro paréntesis ¿Ok? Tenemos que poner en algún punto 3x por 5x
está por aquí y 3x por -7 que está por aquí,
y también no se nos puede olvidar poner 2 por 5x que está aquí y 2 por -7 que está por acá.
Y ahora sí ya que tenemos el desarrollo de esta multiplicación de 2 binomios vamos a simplificarla
3x por 5x nos queda 15x cuadrada
15x cuadrada más 3x por -7
entonces es 3 por -7, -21 por "x"
-21 por "x" y por aquí tenemos 2 por 5 por "x" que es 10x y
finalmente 2 por -7 que es -14.
Y aquí tenemos dos términos que tienen una sola "x" así es que los tenemos que agrupar
y nos queda 10x menos 21x eso es
-11x así es que esta multiplicación de dos binomios nos queda tal cual como
15x cuadrada menos 11x
menos 14 ¿Ok? Este es el resultado de multiplicar estos dos binomios.
Ahora esto lo hicimos siguiendo todo lo que nos dice PAAU.
Sin embargo también lo podemos hacer utilizando dos veces la propiedad distributiva.
A ver acuérdense cuál es la propiedad
distributiva. La propiedad distributiva nos dice que si tenemos aquí un paréntesis
"b" más "c" y lo multiplicamos por "a" esto de aquí es igual a
"a" por "b", "a" por "b"
más "a" por "c", "a" por "c".
¿Ok? Y Vamos a usarlo, lo que quiero mostrarte es que al utilizar dos veces la propiedad
distributiva, al multiplicar estos dos binomios nos queda exactamente
lo mismo que si seguimos todo lo que dice PAAU
¿Ok? Entonces voy a volver a escribir aquí el problema. Tenemos que multiplicar
3x más 2 por
5x menos 7 y entonces lo que vamos a hacer es utilizar la propiedad distributiva
pensando en que todo este paréntesis
es esta "a" de aquí de la propiedad distributiva y entonces vamos a multiplicar todo este paréntesis por
3x y después multiplicar todo este paréntesis por este 2 de aquí
y entonces lo que nos queda es
3x por 5x menos 7 más 2 por 5x menos 7
y ahora lo que vamos a hacer es volver a
utilizar la propiedad
distributiva pero con cada uno de estos paréntesis ¿Ok? Vamos a multiplicar este 3x por el 5x
y a eso le tenemos que sumar 3x por -7
y ya terminamos de usar la propiedad distributiva con este paréntesis.
Así es que vamos a usarla en este paréntesis.
Y aquí tenemos que multiplicar el 2 por el 5x
y sumarle lo que nos quede de multiplicar el 2
por -7 ¿Ok? Y veamos que nos queda, 3x por  5x, eso es
15x cuadrada y ahora 3x por -7
3 por -7, -21 o sea -21x
y de este lado tenemos 2 por 5x o sea
10x y finalmente 2 por -7 o sea
-14 y listo ya desarrollamos esta multiplicación usando dos veces la propiedad
distributiva y lo que nos quedó  es
exactamente lo mismo que nos había quedado por aquí. Usando todo lo que nos dice PAAU ¿Ok?.
Entonces si alguna vez no te acuerdas de qué es lo que nos dice PAAU puedes simplemente
utilizar la propiedad distributiva 2 veces y llegas
exactamente al mismo resultado.